[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur tennis welt ich
bin wieder auf der erst irgendwo jedes
jahr die internationale süßwarenmesse
und hier sind wirklich alle alles frauen
dieser welt gibt steht in verschiedenen
hallen ich starte ganz traditionell sich
hier an und verstand nämlich bei deko
back to back ihr kennt ja schon aus
meinen videos rüdiger den kennt der
sascha und sharon habe ich auch schon
mal gezeigt und zwar machen die torten
dekorationen für zu hause
das heißt dann zum beispiel diese zucker
decken mit denen ich natürlich auch
arbeit und meine motiv torten mache und
hier zeige ich euch mal ganz kurz die
innovationen und dann gehen wir weiter
ich habe mir vorgenommen in diesem video
ich mache eine can decade challenge dh
ich schaue jetzt einfach mal wird die
messe was kann ich für tolle süßigkeit
mitnehmen und daraus später einen can
dick machen
[Musik]
guck mal süsser alpaka sich lieber
alpakas und ich gehe bald eine alpaka
form besuchen
ich werde patentante von alpakas kleine
bildchen die bienchen habe ich ja schon
auf meiner tochter drauf und dann gibt
es natürlich ganz viele andere deko war
reaktionen aber hier muss ich euch noch
was zeigen und zwar das altbekannte
problem bei torsten baier per trocken
zum beispiel alle mögen den boden und
die app aber die meisten die kratzen
immer den bus obendrauf weg der
tortenguss weil klar meistens besteht
auch aus relatives wie essen das dann
auch gar nicht und hier gibt es einen
toten bus zum sprühen und der verhindert
einfach nur dass die erdbeeren zum
beispiel das obst schlecht wird verleiht
den sozusagen um schutz und clowns
er fand orten das ist ja das eine denn
mancher mag es mancher nicht wir mit von
eureka echt super gut arbeiten weil es
einfach alle farben gibt alle
geschmacksrichtungen und den von
anzeigen stärker reduziert zum beispiel
nach vorn an torte gemacht mit flamingos
da habe ich hier noch die kleinen
bienchen draufgeklebt also wirklich
super schnell innerhalb von nicht einmal
zwei stunden habe ich die decke schon
fertig aber manche sagen geben konnten
schön gut aber schmeckt mir nicht ganz
so gut da hat aber der rödiger auf was
und zwar gibt's jetzt dekor marzipan d
commerzbank den hat es auch in
verschiedenen farben deko mann gab
natürlich auch schon vorher ist keine
innovation die innovation ist nur
diesmal funktioniert und es schmeckt
also hier wird es hier drei päckchen
blauen marzahn und der schmeckt zum 61
einfach nach mandeln oder lässt sich
wirklich super verarbeiten wie von damp
beim atse bahn hat mir auch das problem
der smart fahren wirklich immer so koppe
ist und bekommen keine schöne glatte
oberfläche hin
er reist viel zu schnell und er hat mir
wichtig werde ich keine guten vorteile
in einem mann muss man halt auch nicht
wirklich lange kneten also wirklich nur
einmal ganz kurz durchkneten
[Musik]
sie sind bäcker strecke oder brot und
sogar ausrollen und über die torte legen
und man hat natürlich auch den vorteil
dass es aber stabil ist
ich muss zugeben ich habe jetzt keine
becker stattgegeben uns leider aus
deswegen arbeite ich jetzt einfach mit
puderzucker aber butter zu gewinnen hat
mir auch meister heim daher klappt das
auch echt ganz gut
becker stärker natürlich immer den
vorteil dass man sich super einfach
wegwischen kann becker stärke wenn ich
eine kartoffelstärke ganz freien und
kommt nicht
aber hier mit puderzucker knapp zu dem
marzipan echt auch super habe ich hier
meine torte auf messen arbeit ist leider
immer mit styropor torten denn auf der
messebühne tornado schlecht werden aus
stellt euch vor ich habe jetzt hier eine
richtig leckere sahne creme mit einer
einlage mantel bizkit würden
und jetzt kommt hier oben drauf entweder
eine garage oder die creme
ich benutze jetzt einfach
diese wachstumsperle damit davon dann
bzw dem marzipan der gehaftet
und dann heißt auch nicht einfach drüber
weg
schön glatt streichen auf der oberfläche
und hier unten damit so ein bisschen
achten
von dort ist an sich ein bisschen
elastisches marzipan aber ihr seht es
reicht nicht an den ecken und man kriegt
auch schön glatt ohne frage
und dann könnt ihr hier auch wie bei
kontern und einfach die reste
wegschneiden wieder zusammen kneten
luftdicht verpacken und einfach beim
nächsten mal wieder benutzen oder auch
helfen
es gab man sieht doch ganz gut dass mir
ein richtig gut und dünn ausrollen
können
[Musik]
okay es ist schwierig bei der copa de
cuba team eine torte zu finden daher ist
hier keine challenge aber ich bin hier
natürlich richtig coole sachen und zwar
gibt es zum einen ganz neu dieser gold
und silber sterne und die rosa herzchen
und die finde ich super weil sie
wirklich super dünn sind ja über 3000
stern in einem gläschen und ich habe
einfach eine schöne deko auf der torte
oder das ich mir die zähne drauf
ausweise ihr wisst was ich meine diese
harten zuckerperlen die man immer hat
klar ich hab mir jetzt einfach die
schöne deko kann es drüber streuen
einfach ein schönes gibt's das konfetti
glitzer ist sowieso immer dabei gibt's
dann macht alles immer noch schöner und
dann nämlich noch aromen mit und zwar
orangenaroma und petermann lauer
da gibt es auch verschiedene und da kann
ich einfach mit ein paar wenigen tropfen
meinen traum eine creme auch nicht schön
verfeinern und alles ganz natürlich
[Musik]
nein
die meisten kenne ich irgendwie schon
weil wir sind schon so oft hier gewesen
aber jetzt gucke mal nach neuheiten
ich habe jetzt die mission meine torte
habe ich im kopf ihre innovationen und
alle neuheiten dieser gibt
gestolpert
hier gucken war gleich mal vorbei da
gibt es nämlich die neue ruby schokolade
und dies von barry callebaut gefunden
worden und barry callebaut hat fieber
believe diva kennt er ist mein lieblings
morath und da gehen wir gleich mal
vorbei
[Musik]
caramel original - sind immer gut kennt
ihr ja schon die besuche ich jedes jahr
thomas schön dich zu sehen
ich mache dieses jahr eine esm torte
einige handy torte und ich glaub
karamell passt ganz gut in meine tasche
ja ich kenne die bonbons einschmelzen
oder habt ihr parlament creme
wenn das nicht perfektes original
hierfür ein lecker ja nehme ich sehr
gerne mit
die forschung
so wie es aus merken
karamellbonbons zum naschen die creme
fürs brot und für den tortenboden und
der rest ist für euch nicht alles
nämlich die sachen
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich hier bei piper und
heidemann ist eine marke von fifa und
sie war kennt ihr ja schon von den lukas
hiervon wird dieses jahr eine richtige
weltneuheit und zwar habt ihr vielleicht
schon von der hofer schokolade gehört
logitech erneut schokoladensorte nehmen
sagt peter vollmilch und weiße
schokolade ist ruby die vierte
schokoladensorte barry callebaut hat sie
vor 15 jahren entdeckt und hatte zehn
jahre gebraucht um die technik so weit
zu entwickeln dass wirklich die
schokolade richtig gut zum vorschein
kommt und die besonderheit der
schokolade ist die rosa eine farbe die
ist ganz natürlich und auch der
geschmack die schmeckt so leicht
fruchtig weiße schokolade trifft sich so
ganz weiß wirklich ticken anders
schmecken noch viel besser auf jeden
fall und ich war heute morgen schon in
der ruby schockte loch wo eben die
neuheiten vorgestellt worden
ruby ist die jüngste und auch größte
innovation seit über 80 jahren und bei
dem stichwort im innovation da sind wir
ganz ganz vorne immer mit dabei und wir
haben uns heute jemanden eingeladen weil
wir zelebrieren schokolade und die junge
dame die ich gleich hier zu mir bitte
die ist europas größte foodbloggerin und
wir freuen uns hier heute sehr das ist
auch ein persönliches anliegen
sally zu begrüßen denn sally ist unserem
haus nicht einfach nur ein partner
sondern schon fast ein sehr sehr guter
freund
[Musik]
lieber hat er wirklich ganz tolle
kreationen entwickeln
die schauen wir uns gleich mal an und
dann gucke ich mal ob ich da nicht was
für meine torte mit verwenden kann und
der anträge ist und die cloud die haben
bestimmt ein schönes gewinnspiel paket
für euch
ich sehe schon der andreas hat schon
richtig viele tolle sachen für euch
gerichtet
blutig für auf bestes ruby stones und
die schokolade die kann ich ja ganz
normal wie normale schokolade benutzen
einschmelzen und zum beispiel also bin
genau 35 grad schön temperieren nicht so
stark erlebt
ich glaube die nehme ist für die klassen
oder transporte und dann rosa ohne
farbstoffe
und alles andere ist für euch ich habe
schon vorher mehrfach jetzt eingebacken
[Musik]
oval wie schoko frei ist das geht immer
das kann man auch ganz gut einschmelzen
ich frag mal gleich ob ich da eine tafel
nehmen darf und was dir noch neues haben
und das habe ich gestern schon entdeckt
und zwar - neues rettungsboot und
schnaps also peanuts riina ist die marke
richtig genial da gibt es diese peanut
butter kann und hier das finde ich echt
schön vor allem cool gestaltet mit den
ergebnissen auf der oberfläche und innen
hat bei ihm auch diese schöne leckeren
[Musik]
dankeschön einiges verpackungs und der
rest ist für euch danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kamera drauf ist sind wir beim trip ich
habe ihn noch nicht gesagt dass wir
kommen wo bist du
[Musik]
hallo beim philips immer halt immer
weiter immer schön hier und lustig und
die zweige uns wegen unserer familie
ich habe mich gar nicht erkannt dass die
familie hitzschlag roger federer keine
hunde sowie zu hause ja von meinem kopf
murat kaya fuhren die zuschauer denken
ja wissen zurückgebracht wir sind nicht
so ein bisschen verrückt
da brauchst du doch mal meine frau ist
und auflösen und obendrein bereinigungen
ja
[Musik]
also der bulli ist praktischer 58 und
basiert auf dem original mit dem
controller großvater süßigkeiten
verkauft hat werde ich deutschland
gefahren ist und hat richtig hier ja mit
dem lieferwagen bulli t1 sollte das
alles verkauft hier drin war die ware
drin und wir nutzen jetzt als promotion
mobil den fahrer mit den handelspartnern
abgehen auf events gehen auf menschen
kommt sieht so aus als wenn philipp in
essen dabei oder ja auch nichts normal
besprechen oder bei der einweihungsfeier
werden muss jede frau ist allerdings nur
ein paar süßigkeiten ich bin ein
handicap challenger richtig schöne torte
[Musik]
so jetzt trommelwirbel
jetzt gibt es die weltmeere ich bin da
echt stolz drauf dass philipp hat mir
gerade gezeigt die hitze erobern jetzt
die welt amerika richtig echt cool ich
muss echt sagen er sei zwar innovativ
denn hier hinunter auf den client will
mit unterschrift kind einfach immer
schön wenn eine firma angesicht hat um
skip dieser firma ein gesicht ja ist
genau das die leute wollen park hinter
die kulissen gucken was die wollen
müssen oster sehen steckt hinter der
qualität mehr hat genau die idee
dahinter und deshalb auch eben hippies
candy girls sagen meine kennen die world
und das ist stoff für amerika genau das
richtige
herr von sauer und laut lustig auf die
verpackung wird ein sehr spannender weg
ich bin so stolz drauf hat angefangen
mit seinem urgroßvater und jetzt geht es
in die ganze welt wie es in der ganzen
welt
ich denke auch bewerbs war cool unsere
welt was für ein cooles familien futter
oder von uns hat er im
familienunternehmen deswegen gebe ich
euch jetzt bei euch angefangen mein
großvater dass er gegründete kloster
stimme tourbus vater bin auf
vertriebsleiters gegründet und dann ist
mein großer der gang weiter hitzschlag
und dann sagen meine mutter und jetzt
eben man mich in vierter generation
haben wir letztes jahr und macht viel
spaß und macht spaß mit ihr zu tun aber
als familie ist man stark und steht dazu
sachen werden noch viel vor und ich
werde ein paket für euch richten lassen
jedes gewinnen und ich pack damit noch
eine torte war sehr cool edition schon
in meiner meinung frauenschutzhaus doch
wie gut ach die haben perfekt gepasst
auch candy
jetzt gehe ich mein versprechen einlösen
wir gehen jetzt zum sven und das wenn es
mein freund denn sven hat alpakas und
wir kriegen weiß als der gast 50 wird
patentante von einem alpaka
[Musik]
was bekommst du hin unter einer minute
alles klar
ich bin gespannt zeit der körper steht
schon
stock graf 24 72 bisschen mehr als 20
aber hallo
ein teddybär in 25 sekunden den
lieblingsrennen dynamisch toll willst
dass das andere austria ist ist mir
schon klar ich bin einfach ich habe mein
ziel habe ich keine genannt wenn du
deinen als pkw die sally newswires wir
überlegen ich sag dir bescheid christe
geburtstag
ich werde jetzt mit ran team von einem
acker unternehmer vier firma geführt
ja wir leben kann eure familie 1 murat
wild yam 116i kommen
wir nehmen einfach versuchen die farbe
aus dass geschwächt aus und jeder kann
sich ganz außen schicke euch eine liste
mit fotos ich kenne sie ja dann ford
plant zu lassen dann haben wir später
irgendwann ganz alpaka familie und wir
machen kein problem machen und wissen
unser freund sven den haben wir letztes
jahr auch schon besucht sie paaren in
chile in hülle und fülle aber ihr habt
ihr nicht normal zu fahren macht er
alles passen dem anderen zu tun alles
wir haben jetzt ganz tolle neue produkte
wir fangen jetzt an mit mandel mandelöl
ganz toll
wir hatten uns ja wir haben uns darüber
unterhalten was man also man kann die
mandeln und natürlich ein salatöl packen
also als salatöl besitzen
man kann man die zum backen benutzen
überall da wo rein geht darf man aber
der rauch punkt ist relativ weit hinten
also deswegen vorsichtig sein man kann
man zu massieren ja total toll
der monat sollte dann anfang märz
passieren und wenn das alles nicht
funktioniert kann man sieben jahre
schmieren auf die haut partner als ist
kosmetik das super gut
das nennt man genau man das finde ich
genial
ich kenne es noch schlimmer mandeln nuss
und zahnpasta gemischt mit hartz iv
machen das haben wir uns eher mauer
du kannst daraus aber auch dann lagen im
handel nicht machen nicht das heißt wenn
du das nimmst und ein bisschen wasser
drauf passt und dann ein bisschen rührt
und dann hast oder mit tattoos dann
kannst du daraus eine eigene mandl mich
machen die so gesund ist und du kannst
voran den mangel gehalt bestimmen was
heißt du hast viel mehr man will indem
man nämlich als sonst dann so richtig
auf
dann werde ich dies ist wenn ich darf
mitnehmen zum backen darfst du nicht
eine handykarte was den mitnehmen sollte
es ist mandl mail
weil das ist ihm frei und da kannst du
total gute sachen mitmacht immer so
lustigen geschmack nimmt man zu sagen
das gericht die auch mit ja das patent
paket für meine zuschauer das malen auf
alle verletzt weil auch ihr soll zuhause
buccaneer sollte es zu hause mal
ausprobieren das totale leckere mandl
mir immer probieren mit dem leicht
nussigen geschmack und der vorteil ist
wir haben geröstete mandeln genommen das
heißt unser manuel hat auch echt super
mandl bismarck
[Musik]
japanische kinder lädt gedacht na
endlich
hier kann man ja gar nicht durch ich
weiß dass nadja ist nach moritz der
shooting-star hier auf der messe bei dir
war die hölle los deswegen habe ich
gesagt ich komme später nochmal schöner
ist ja genau bei mir war die hölle los
weil wir sind wohl die einzigen die hier
halal und koscher anbieten ja also ganz
offiziell produkte vielleicht kennst
auch schon die ein oder andere ich
glaube ist da länder sagt einigen thoma
ist der kalender mit den schokoladen
für den ramadan in erwachsene wir sind
und kinder versorgen kinder wenn sie
dieses jahr dass die erwachsenen aber
ihr habt ihr nicht nur den raum hat ein
rentner sein der auch zu tragen und alle
anderen sachen gesetzlichkeiten
schokolade schokolade zehnmal also wir
haben schokoladen wir haben tat
schockiert wir sind spezialisiert auf
das zertifizieren und halal und koscher
da fragen viele was ist dann schokolade
haben ja angst zu auch mit halb bei
alles was für uns gut ist noch alles was
für uns gut ist und dass man muss gar
nicht gerade klein sondern man hat so
was wie ein doppelcheck sag ich immer
nach
wir haben sechs ist nachhaltig du hast
keine künstlichen aromen kein hamburg
keine gelatine also gerade mit kindern
oder hanken leuten also es ist super ich
muss dir gut tun
was ist das es ist lacht mich ja das ist
ja das ist unser neustes produkt das ist
großartig dass macadamia nuss die ich
schokolade manchmal kann jetzt nicht
mehr reden weil nach dem magna mit
ja ja herkommen
ok ich suche mir sicher zum backen
ich mache nämlich in der candy cane ja
super weiterhin wäre es beim spritzen
gerne
[Musik]
jetzt einfach mal mit wenig familie
glücklich machen will dann gibt's cookie
dough essbarer keks tag ohne ein kind es
sei wahrscheinlich jedes kind jedermann
oder jeder selber löffelt gerne den teig
aus der rührschüssel meine mama hat aber
früher immer fix tag extra für uns
gemacht
hier könnte den jetzt ganz einfach
selber an mission ohne ein
und wenn ich was gutes für murat tun
will nehme ich diese edition für ihn mit
schwarz gelb das schlägt sein herz dafür
und wenn ich schon sauer machen will
nämlich rot blau aber ich muss sagen ich
bin fertig sieht mich da nicht mit rein
ich bin für keine mannschaft oder für
alle
ich will dass alle gewinne kann ich mich
gut drauf gerät ist
wie stark eine milchpackung koch nur
zieht mich nirgends mit rein tötet mich
nicht wegen den mannschaften
ich nehme was für euch mit zum verlosen
ok einfach schreiben was hier drunter
steht
[Musik]
hallo kooperation mit einem weniger
gesprochen
er ist nicht nur ein manager ist ein
mann und sein manager sozusagen
handgemachte tranche könnte quasi jedes
produkt rajeev ram bringt akteure machen
die wir hören ist schokolade
wir können aber auch verschiedene
minister nehmen oder besondere genüsse
und die machen einen besonderen
schokoladen haben wir ganz wichtig story
stecke mahnungen machen aber quatsch
immer dann passieren wenn wir haben ja
das sind die muster wie wir es gemacht
haben wie pfefferminze erdbeeren sind
halt immer verschiedene produkte die wir
in verschiedenen schokoladen basieren
und die man halt besonders in long 80
pergament grün wahrscheinlich hat jetzt
kennt man normalerweise von betty
fruchtgummi letztes jahr war ich auch
hier am stand und jetzt gehen sie ganz
neue wege denn es gibt einen leckeren
regeln ich probiere mich mal durch
welches der beste
fertig
in hamburg
was ist da drin hanfsamen brauner reis
sirup getrocknete cranberries anderem
steven reiss stärke kürbis käme oder
ungesunde snacks zwischendurch
[Musik]
jetzt gehe ich nach meinem nachbarn
besuchen seit vier jahren war hier am
stand weiter kompakt zum einstand
nachbar einer bevor ist daraufhin in der
hand voll die leckeren cantuccini und
reese das lag hat sich ja auch mal im
auto
ich möchte eine esm torte machen
das heißt viele tolle leckere zutaten
und so ein gewinnpaket für meine
zuschauer dass ich mir die videos aus
stimmt was ich denke wir haben ganz gut
wenn man jetzt so schauer so ein kleines
tütchen ja ich denke immer an euch
danke
[Musik]
tamira paszek mal
er hat gerade keine kaugummi tasche weiß
ich aber ich gucke gleich noch auf den
messen bringe ich die kaufen und mit ok
mit kampf sieben größten vom blut und
natürlich schnell auf ich kann nämlich
zaubernacht
ich habe gezögert da würde ich gar nicht
keine taschen
alles für euch sind alle die vielleicht
noch nie was mit vom land macht am könnt
ihr zum beispiel der rolle von landeck
er gebraucht das ist jeden fall nur eine
weiße oder oder flieder
alpaka weise einfacher mache ich kriege
noch mehr staub und die bienen schon mal
ein bisschen abenteuer charme einer
torte kümmern
viele waren zu befestigen neue farben
spaziergänger schwer translate weil ich
trocken
neuen schmetterlingen und schmetterlinge
die die pizza stern dessen höhe die hier
kippe stehen
[Musik]
goldenen und silbernen sternen es reicht
für ungefähr 60 bis 70
und an elektro- und die aromen desto
mehr tatenlos sprechen
stärker machen
als
doch jetzt schnell ein must have
pfizer schnee
wenn es dir nicht gefällt streue glitzer
drüber und dann wird schön hotspots für
ausgemacht
noch mit mantel und orangen ich muss es
auch verschicken können
demgegenüber mittel schon sehr schön was
sie sagen bei den meisten sachen dieser
saison
die sind dann schnell aufgefordert aber
davon ab märz mehrere monate war
jedenfalls lang trocken und cupcakes
dekorieren
da halloween balkon das hier ist meine
ausbeute von der esm und das ist
wirklich nur die ausbeute von etwa einem
tag alles für euch daraus werde ich
jetzt zum einen die torte zu bereiten
und zum anderen sind die süßigkeiten
eben dann für euch ein highlight auf der
messe war auf jeden fall die ruby
schokolade die ruby schokolade ist
nämlich die vierte schokoladensorte
neben zartbitter vollmilch und weißer
schokolade und wurde letztes jahr
entdeckt und jetzt hat fieber dieser
schokolade bekommen und stellt daraus
richtig coole leckere süßigkeiten her
aber was man ganz gut sehen kann
es gibt zwei trendbewegungen die eine
trendbewegung ist umweltfreundlicher
magee weniger zucker und die andere
trendbewegung ist alles to go also ihr
kennt ja zum beispiel hier schoko eis in
dieser groß verpackung und dann gibt es
eben von vielen herstellern auch noch
die turbo variante für die handtasche
finde ich auch super praktisch weil ich
ja nicht so ein riesen verpackung
mitnehmen kann aber unterwegs vielleicht
doch mal was machen möchte und da
versucht man einfach immer zum einen
umweltschonenden umweltfreundlicher zu
werden aber zum anderen eben auch dieses
schnelle leben zu füllen also mit diesen
sachen togo
das sind so zwei gegensätzliche
trendbewegungen finde ich ansonsten fand
ich die smw immer ganz cool vor allem
ein würdiger bei der coba hat mir sehr
gut gefallen und jetzt werde ich
versuchen aus tiefen zutaten eine
richtig coole candy kate trotter zu
machen wenn ihr wissen wollt wie die
aussieht dann schaut euch einfach das
video dazu an
und diese sachen verlose ich dann an
euch und das könnt ihr dann auch
kommentieren in meinem torten video also
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]